for years russian fossil fuels have been
a main energy source for much of europe
on an average day the eu buys in as much
as one billion dollars worth of coal gas
and oil
but moscow is now insisting customers
from what it calls hostile states pay
for their gas in rubles
and have switched off supply to the
bulgarians and poles for failing to do
so
forcing the eu into an emergency meeting
on energy security many european energy
companies are due to make the next
payment to gas from in mid-may
and are trying to understand better
what they should do
and we need to give them the clarity
that paying rubles
through the conversion mechanisms
managed by the russian public
authorities
and a second dedicated account in
castron bank is a violation of the
sanctions and cannot be accepted
in essence this meeting deferred lasting
solutions leaving that option instead
for a full eu summit at the head of
state level at the end of the month
the sticking point has been how to help
member states who are most dependent on
russian energy so what they want to know
who's going to take care of them and is
there solidarity in the european union
it's one thing you have solidarity when
everybody's storage is full will there
be solidarity when storage isn't full
and that's germany for example has the
biggest storage after ukraine we know
the problem in ukraine they should step
up and say we're going to share with you
what we can
the european commission has already said
it wants to reduce its dependence on
russian energy by two-thirds this year
but the german government wants to act
sooner where possible agreeing to
embargo russian coal from august and
wanting to stop using its oil by the end
of the summer with gas to follow as
quickly as possible
which means uncertainty for refineries
such as schwett in eastern germany each
year it processes more than 11 million
tons of russian crude oil it's currently
majority owned by the moscow-based
company rosneft in some ways berlin's
changing approach to russian fossil
fuels has been a process not an event
when the war started ministers avoided
encouraging embargoes
but as the conflict in ukraine has
evolved so too has their position here
dominic kane al jazeera in the german
capital